so at the time the Santa Claus came out
there was actually a little bit of a
risk factor to it in that nobody knew if
Tim Allen could actually carry a film we
knew he could carry a sitcom okay but
that was sort of the standard formula
that was repeated over and over and yeah
does that translate well into not only a
theatrical film but a Christmas film and
the answer is yes he does but not as
much the story which is a good set up
but doesn't give much else on top of it
the movie centers around Tim Allen being
a divorced dad with a son he's trying to
find a way to spend more time with him
around Christmas and sure enough he
accidentally yells at Santa Claus who's
on top of his roof causing him to lose
his footing and yes killing some pretty
dark actually trying to make his son
feel better he takes off the suit and
puts it on not realizing they he's
actually entering into the Santa Claus
with Annie get it so now he has the job
of delivering all the gifts to all the
kids around the world he tries to
decline it but over time he seems to
keep putting on weight growing long hair
and yes even a white beard eventually he
finds he just can't turn away and
decides to take the job all while his
son starts telling everybody and of
course they don't believe him and then
he's roped in and then nobody believes
him but of course they'll be proven
wrong in the end and god I hate these
stories if it was more funny I'd be more
open to it but that's one of its major
problems it's not that funny now to the
film's credit I don't think it's trying
to be that funny I think it's trying to
be more whimsical magical and it does
have certain elements of that the North
Pole is a lot of fun it definitely has
some decent effects there is certainly
this idea that they want to give the
size and weight to Santa while also
throwing in a little comedy but again
the key words are little comedy when you
have Tim Allen as Santa Claus you know
you want a lot of funny stuff and they
don't really do that much it's more
trading it in for this story of him
trying to convince everyone he's Santa
Claus nobody believing him and then
people getting more concerned and just
ah you know where it's gonna go so why
are we watching it well maybe a few
reasons are that Tim Allen's not bad he
definitely has a charm factor to him and
to help him out he has some
join Wells as well I found interesting
that in this rendition the ELLs are
played by kids not little people and
they're still supposed to be older like
some are several hundred years old but
they look like little kids I guess
that's our way of getting past child
labor laws at first I was somewhat
offended by this because I thought hey
isn't that kind of taking jobs away from
little people by having kids acted
instead but the more I thought about it
the North Pole does look a little bit
more jolly with a bunch of kids running
around and yeah I know they're not
really kids in this but come on they're
kids and they're happy and they're
cheerful and yeah it just makes the
place seem more upbeat which is not to
say grown adults in the role aren't
upbeat but you can't capture it like you
can with a kid so I think it's fine
especially knowing that the majority of
elf roles are still gonna have little
people in a the North Pole is a nice
looking North Pole it's very bright and
colorful and definitely has a large
scale to it and yeah it's obviously a
sad but I don't mind it still has sort
of that magical element to it but is
there enough magic in this movie to
overlook a painfully obvious story in my
opinion no but for a lot of other people
yes if you can put up with that kind of
story and don't really mind it then
there's still plenty of other elements
on top of it to be enjoyable just not
enough for me to get into it it's not
the worst it's just kind of boring for
me but again if it doesn't bother you
then I think this film will be a fun
magical ride I just think there's more
that can be explored and done with this
idea but hey that's what we have sequels
for and I'll join you over in the next
video for those
you